a way to stop her coronation that pawn
yeah yeah the Queens are coming off and
with it pregnant and his chances
disappear he's going to be eliminated
he's had so much success this season
pregnant is basically only been going up
up up up up up at some point obviously
some disappointment will come so is it
now for him to deal with this
disappointment and come back next
tournament
I mean he had a tough okay the first
couple of days were great but the tough
second half of the prelims he didn't win
for eight games he still made it through
still nearly got there today into the
playoffs so I mean that's an art form
the top players Master at playing well
when you're out of shape and uh yeah
he'll come back he'll be stronger he's
getting better and uh okay Vincent
deserved this match so you can't take
anything away from either player here
this black porn is about to make a new
Queen and Prague resigns it's over
Vincent kaimer the young German 17 years
old he is ready to face Magnus Carlson
in a semi-final